In Israel, a young man who is suspected of making threatening calls to US Jewish community centers...
...also directed threats to Australia and New Zealand.
In France, presidential candidates Emmanuel Macron and Marine Le Pen appear tied in polls,...
...but uncertainty remains towards the election outcome.
In Iraq, children who were caught in the crossfires of the Mosul battle...
...were rushed to the hospital.
In Afghanistan, due to growing insecurity and shrinking international funding,...
...nearly one in three children will miss school.
And finally from Nigeria,...
...162 Nigerians were deported from Libya in a continuing crackdown.